now two American perspectives and Jeff
Bezos the founder and CEO of amazon.com
was Time magazine's Person of the Year
in 1999 last month he sat down with
Stephen Shepherd of Businessweek
magazine for discussion about the future
of the online retail business this one
hour 20 minute event took place at the
92nd Street Y in New York City thank you
very much Alain a good evening and
welcome everyone we're most fortunate in
having Jeff Bezos founder and CEO of
amazon.com as our guest tonight our
format as some of you know is very very
simple after I introduced Jeff he will
come out we will sit down in those
chairs and have a conversation for 45 or
50 minutes and then we will turn it over
to you we mean this to be an audience
participation show and welcome your
questions so please fill out the cards
and hand them over to people who will
collect them and we won't think you rude
if you are writing out questions while
we're talking in creating and building
Amazon Jeff Bezos has invented something
fundamentally new an online retail store
that stresses service customization and
a great brand in sales last year hit 2.7
billion dollars up 68 percent over the
year before in 1999 he was named Time
Magazine's Man of the Year the last
couple of years have not been overly
kind to Amazon the company lost seven
hundred and nineteen million dollars in
1999 and one point four billion dollars
in 2000 the stock although it's had a
nice run the last three or four days is
nonetheless down from its high of a
hundred and thirteen dollars in late
1999 to $13.32
as of closing today which is the Cline
of 88% amazon has had to layoff 1,300
people and close the warehouse or two
the question everyone is asking is
whether Amazon will turn a profit before
it runs out of cash and we'll try to
find that out tonight Jeff likes to say
he has built an e-commerce platform made
up of its customers its brand its
technology its e-commerce expertise and
its distribution capabilities on this
platform he says it is far easier and
cheaper to build new businesses Amazon
started out in July 1995 by selling only
books but has now become the internet's
number one retailer of lots of other
stuff more than 35% of its customers in
the United States by electronic gear
kitchen supplies Hardware toys and games
Amazon wants to get to know its
customers Jeff says in the same way a
small town shopkeeper of yesteryear
might have gotten to know them that kind
of personalization is going to be
extremely valuable for the customer
Atilla straight if you go on the
amazon.com site under family and
favorites you can find out the best
selling books in our towns among people
in our occupations and among employees
in our companies by the way the
best-selling book among Amazon employees
is Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire
so I guess Amazon employees aren't so
different from the rest of us the number
seven bestseller by the way is called
the worst case scenario survival
handbook will left him explain that but
first let's do a little personalization
about Jeff he grew up in Houston
his father Miguel left Cuba in the early
1960s and became an executive at Exxon
his mother Jacqueline worked in
a bank Jef spent summers on a family
farm in Texas developing a love for
science from his grandfather a retired
manager the Atomic Energy Commission by
the time he was 14 he wanted to be an
astronaut or a physicist the family
garage was always filled with his
products projects from a vacuum cleaner
on its way to becoming a hovercraft - an
umbrella soon to be a solar cooker Jeff
flexed his entrepreneurial muscles in
high school he thought up the dream
institute a summer school program to
encourage creative thinking in young
school kids then he made his brother
mark and sister Christine pay to attend
jeff was a perennial overachiever
valedictorian and president of his high
school class at Princeton he earned
degrees in electrical engineering and
computer science summa [ __ ] laude after
Princeton he appeared to be headed for a
nerdy tech career instead he worked for
Bankers Trust Company here in New York
for four years and then he landed a
hedge fund operated de Shaw and company
where he quickly latched on to the net
soon he was heading across the country
by car to start Amazon legend has it
that he typed the business plan on a
laptop and called investors on a cell
phone as his wife drove her name by the
way is Mackenzie she's here with us
tonight
and she's a novelist for the first four
years at Amazon Jeff worked so much that
he and Mackenzie couldn't find time to
move out of their tiny studio apartment
now they have a toddler
Preston another on the way and
presumably a bigger place to live
although I didn't ask him through it all
jeff has not lost any of his charm or a
sense of humor his hyper kinetic energy
provides a lot of Amazon's electricity
and I'm confident in saying that Jeff
has the loudest laugh in Seattle perhaps
the loudest laugh anywhere ladies and
gentlemen please join me in welcoming
the founder and CEO of Amazon
komm Jeff Bezos
nice to see you nice to see you too
thank you for being with us I'll try not
to burst anybody's eardrums but you know
hopefully they passed out prophylactic
earplugs on the way and I think that
would be very important less they
already heard you from backstage let's
back up and start the start at the
beginning with the idea for Amazon yeah
how did you get this idea when how well
I was the hedge fund I worked I was a
client ativ hedge fund we used eunuchs
everywhere you know mosaic was the first
graphical browser on the World Wide Web
and in 1994 in the UNIX community a lot
of people were talking about mosaic and
the World Wide Web and it was growing
explosively David Shaw my boss assigned
me to look at different things that de
Shah & Co the company might do in in it
in and in and around the internet and
the more I poked around it and I found
this one fact which I found just
astonishing not on a website I found the
web usage was growing at 2,300 percent a
year
this is a time when nobody could know
what the baseline usage was but it was
quite easy to figure out the growth rate
and anything that doesn't have a
completely trivial baseline that's
growing that fast is invisible today and
ubiquitous tomorrow and that really was
sort of the wake-up call for me and I
went and got a book on mail order and
looked at all the different categories
that do by what do well by mail order
and started force ranking those and
shifting them around books is near the
bottom of that list and but it became
clear that the reason that books wasn't
a great mail-order product is because
you can't put a decent selection in a
catalogue in a paper catalogue it's
impossible so from from that point about
15 months later we launched amazon.com
in July of 95 and at that time we
launched with a million titles which is
you know five or six times as many
titles as you'd find even the largest
superstore and
and if you were to print that in a paper
catalog it would have been the size of
13 New York City phone books so that was
the sort of the insight that led to
amazon.com now is that story true that
you actually typed out the business plan
well the first draft of the business
plan was indeed written on the way the
idea was already well formulated a lot
of research had been done but the first
tract it's not true however legends grow
it's not true however that I called
investors on the way I did call a lawyer
on the way from the cell phone and I
said you know this is a lawyer in
Seattle a local lawyer and who I just
gotten from a friend strangely this was
a general practitioner you know you kind
of think of this in grand terms but this
had been my friends divorce attorney and
and I called this guy up and and just
said you know I need you could you
incorporate the company and open some
bank accounts for us because when I get
to Seattle I want to already be hitting
the ground running and I don't want to
have to do some of this stuff like
incorporation and have that done and he
said sure that's no problem easy to do
what do you want the name of the company
to be and over the cell phone I said
Cadabra as an abracadabra
and he said cadaver it was pretty clear
at that point that that wasn't good not
a good name yeah yeah how do you spell
cadaver yeah no so the the name we
changed the name about three months
later it wasn't officially incorporated
as Cadabra Inc and then changed about
three months later to amazon.com now
when you had the idea was it just books
or did you imagine that at some point it
would be it really was just books and
and and the and the reason for that is
startup companies need to be absolutely
laser focused you know so many startup
companies I see and I talked to
entrepreneurs and I see them they have
too many things going at once and it's
really really important when you have
these you know you have these initial
precious resources and they're so very
finite that you need to be very focused
and we expect it to slowly grow the
business out of cash flow as most
businesses are grown
you have to remember that in the you
know when we were putting together the
plans for this and even when we launched
it in July 95 the this was the Internet
was a very small place compared to what
you saw in 98 99 and 2000 and certainly
people weren't raising millions of
dollars you know amazon.com was started
with a few hundred thousand dollars most
of which came from my my parents always
a good source of angel investment
capital the ultimate patient investors
yeah that's right and you know I told
them I thought there was a 70% chance
they would lose their investment and and
that's because if you look at the
statistics there's a 90% chance that
they lose their investment I decided I
would give myself triple the normal odds
because I'm so confident optimistic so
that you know and but I really wanted to
know there was a good chance they lose
their money because I wanted to be able
to come home for Thanksgiving
so it worked out very well for them of
course which I'm extraordinarily happy
about I'm sure that it was great faith
believe me there is no you know my dad's
first question was what's the internet
so this wasn't you know this was they
were investing in their son not this
idea and and it's another reason why
parents make such good angel investors
well good for them
you've now branched out to a lot of
products
what what are the products would you
consider from this point on and all
their products that are just you know
not suitable at all well so different
products will be suitable to different
degrees probably you know books is
clearly one of the best and the reason
that we tried to do it we did it first
as the internet gets more sophisticated
more and more product categories become
possible if you if you can think back
five years which is difficult because
everybody forgets that was when
everybody called the World Wide Web the
world wide wait the fastest modems that
the average person had were about
fourteen dot for a few people had twenty
eight eight modems the browser's crashed
every 15 minutes it was an incredibly
primitive and infant technology it's
still very primitive compared to where
it will be five years from now
but but that when you have you know such
a primitive technology you can only do a
very prescribed number of things as the
technology gets better and better you're
able to do a larger larger number of
things and so you know I'm for one you
know one of the categories that I'm very
very optimistic about is our electronics
business and they're just a lot of
economic advantages to selling
electronics online again we can have the
selection advantage we have twenty five
thousand different electronics items in
our store compared to about five
thousand in a big electronic superstore
so I think there'll be a lot of
categories and even some of the
categories that initially fail like
furniture and pets both of which we were
major investors in well we will fail and
then they'll come back and again yeah
ultimately is there much crossover you
know do people bahu buy books by lawn
mowers sure yeah yeah not in New York
City the books of the lawn mowers they
buy the books here yeah well they maybe
we made the right choice the books are
more fun you know but there is crossover
I mean sure your fires will buy kitchen
stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah that's right
try the Aqsa salad spinner I challenge
everybody in this room to read the
customer reviews for the Aqsa salad
spinner and then not buy an ox a salad
spinner they read like sexual
experiences I mean it's really it's an
extraordinary set of reviews I anyway
and it is a good coating a porn site
yeah and it salads pinning site so what
what are the products you think will
drive the future growth well I mean
short run next 2-3 years well for us
right now the the the segments of our
business that are growing the fastest
are our international segment which is
which is books music video software
actually in Japan it's just books today
but also then in the US it's the what we
call early stage businesses which is
mostly our our hard lines businesses so
it's electronics it's tools it's kitchen
those are the businesses that are
growing the fastest
are those higher margin businesses than
books and music so it depends if you're
looking at dollar profit per item the
answer is yes so this is one of the
things that I think gets frequently
misunderstood especially in the
electronics category where you know
let's say you're talking about a 300
dollar digital camera that may have a
15% gross margin or 10% gross margin but
that's still 30 or 45 dollars of gross
profit if you take a $20 book that may
have a 30% gross margin which sounds
better but it's really only six dollars
of gross profit so and we you know if
you look at our the way we do things we
have distribution centers it costs us
about the same to receive stow pick sort
pack and ship a digital camera as it
does a book so the camera can actually
be much more profitable even though the
gross margins are lower right right now
you have had this very good partnership
with Toys R Us benefit to you and or is
absolutely they've been fantastic
partners will you look for other such
partnerships I mean beyond what you'd
announce today with right orders mhm
yeah I think there's an opportunity
there you know one of the things that
we've done over the last six years is
build a platform and it consists of
those things you listed at the beginning
and and the way we built that platform
is by thinking exclusively about our own
customers so you know we wanted to make
the website very easy to use we wanted
the distribution centers and so on to
work reliably we wanted customer service
to work reliably this all this stuff
together made us very good at e-commerce
and I think widely recognized by just
about everybody even really by our
critics as the best possible online
shopping experience and what we're
finding is that there are a lot of
physical world companies Toys R Us and
borders being you know the first two
examples that have found it's very very
difficult to do a good job online
and so they are you know they've teamed
up with us so that they can focus on
their in-store experience which is a
very difficult business in its own right
and then by partnering with us have a
top you know a plus quality rating that
offering for their online commerce so
when the arrangement with Toys R Us you
essentially do the front end that's
right the selling and the back end and
the shipping and so on is done by Toys R
Us what case actually um we do all of
the shipping and fulfillment we do all
the physical handling of the merchandise
but we don't own the inventory so we
handle the inventory but Toys R Us owns
the inventory and that's very important
because in the toy business one of the
hardest things about the business is
buying in March for what you know the
ten year olds are going to want in
December so that's such a difficult
thing and such a critically important
competency in that business that it's so
much easier for Toys R Us to do it than
us but we actually are physically really
but once all that merchandise is in our
distribution centers why wouldn't you
take it to the next step and say you're
really unique at the front end the
virtual store and they're you know they
know how to ship toys well they're doing
bricks and mortar part you do the
virtual part they what we're finding is
that the bricks and mortar companies
don't really don't know how to do the
backend part of our business because
it's completely different yeah we are
one of the only actually as far as we
know we're the only company that has a
distribution center network that ships
millions of SKUs millions of different
items to millions of different customers
so if you look at the distribution
center network of a major you know
leading retailer like Toys R Us they
will have very sophisticated
distribution center infrastructure but
its purpose built and designed to ship
cartons of product to stores not single
items to customers and it's a completely
different thing in fact you emphasize
different things think about it in the
if you're shipping things to stores and
if somebody orders you know a hundred of
something
if a store orders a hundred of something
and you ship them 95 that's actually
okay or if they order you ship from 105
that's also okay as long as you're
keeping track of it but that's not okay
if it's an individual customer so you
need much higher levels of accuracy than
you do when people when customers are
picking the items off the shelves
themself
would you consider doing just being the
user interface for some bricks and
mortar company which would handle the
total back-end sure I mean it's what we
the way we look at this platform is its
assembled from a number of pieces so
there's the website which has
personalization and one-click shopping
and search and browse technology that
corrects misspellings and you know all
the things that are designed to make it
easy that's a very important piece of
what we have to offer there's the
customer service and fulfillment that's
a very important piece and there's a you
know access to amazon.com that customer
base that's another piece and so if you
if you sort of look at these different
pieces you know I suspect that you know
different partners will want you know to
sort of assemble an offering out of
different pieces and and we're agnostic
about that as long as it's good for the
partner good for us and great for the
customer as long as all three of those
parties benefit will be interested right
and then you can leverage your
investment that's exactly right
all right let's get down to the money
questions which you've been asked about
a lot I've never heard these questions
before cumulatively you've lost a fair
amount of money you're losing less than
you lost last quarter but you're still
losing give us some idea of when you
think Amazon will start making money
well so our short-term goal in that
regard is as a first step we would like
to have a pro-forma
operating profit this q4 and you know
for five years we've declined to even
answer that question until just recently
and the reason was we didn't feel like
we had enough
ability to responsibly answer that
question and now we feel like we do
we've just had you know five quarters of
of progress in you know it some
important operational metrics and in our
pro forma applause numbers and so that's
the thing that's giving us the
visibility you know there are no
guarantees and there can't be to make
that forecast now explain to everyone
what you mean by pro forma because that
that's not the same as net income which
is the traditional there are two things
so there's there's there's pro forma and
there's there's pro forma versus gap and
there's operating versus net so
operating income is different from net
income because operating income excludes
taxes and interest primarily you know
because we're in a lost position and
have significant loss carryforwards for
us the difference between net and
operating is primarily net interest
expense the difference between pro forma
and gap is largely a bunch of non-cash
charges that primarily relate to you
know goodwill of acquisitions you know
investments that we made that didn't
work out and we wrote down things like
that so the prediction is about pro
forma earnings Cravath quarter of this
year you'll be in the black and a pro
forma basis which will include goodwill
and those items you just mentioned are
you able to make a dick - I think it
excludes I mean excellent writes
momentously wasn't it trick question
plain old mystic are you in a position
to talk about net income no we're not
and we will you know we will make those
forecasts as we get closer but at this
point in time we're taking it one step
at a time we're making a very precise
prediction and and you know there's a
lot of work to make that you know it's
not a slam dial well let's talk about we
feel very good about it and what does it
change for you to start making money
more customers higher prices lower cost
fewer products more products but
servus what most of the change that
we're driving is on is in various kinds
of operating efficiencies so if you look
at what we did over the last five years
we follow the strategy of get big fast
and that was a really important thing to
do and the team that we have at the
company really focused on it very
strongly and it worked if you look at us
versus most of the other competitors in
our space and by the way the way we did
that was by doing a great job for
customers it wasn't that we were genius
marketers or anything else our best
marketing dollars have always been spent
on making the website better and easier
to use and making distribution centers
and customer service better those are
the that those are our best marketing
dollars so we've done a great job of
that and then what we have to do is turn
a good portion of that focus which was
devoted to growth to operating
efficiency you know in it was only three
and a half years ago it's very hard to
remember that when we at the time of our
IPO
we had annualized sales of about sixty
million dollars a year now when you have
sales of sixty million dollars a year if
you can get a 1% operating efficiency by
doing a bunch of hard work that will net
you over the course of the year one
percent of sixty million which is about
six hundred thousand dollars that's not
very much money and really what you
should be doing is instead of investing
all that executive bandwidth time energy
hardworking people on trying to get that
1% operating efficiency you should
instead be trying to build a company of
the scale where 1% matters and we are
now clearly at that point in fact you
know about 18 months ago we really
started on that inflection point
changing the way we manage the business
to put more emphasis on operating
efficiency because now with you know 2.7
billion dollars in sales 1% is no longer
$600,000 it's 27 million dollars these
are big numbers so we've got tons of
headroom in operating efficiency for
example we have fulfillment expense
which is the distribution centers the
customer service centers credit card
expense that's a year ago was 16 percent
of sales in q4 99 in q4 mm that was
about 13 and a half percent of sales so
you know we got about 250 basis points
two and a half percent in that in that
area and we believe or the long term
that that can be in the high single
digits but there's just a tremendous
amount of work to do there and by the
way it's incredibly fun in lecture
challenging work it's every bit as much
fun as being focused on making sure that
we achieve the scale necessary to be a
lasting company yeah well there's a
trade-off here I mean you know you could
say we would go to five billion dollars
without worrying about profitability you
could say we should have gone for
profitability as a somewhat smaller
company in retrospect do you think it
would have been bread it better to grow
a little more slowly and and get the
profitability sooner I actually suspect
that we've probably timed things about
right that the reason that scale is so
important in this business is because
the fixed costs are so high and the and
the variable costs are relatively low
compared to a physical store so you know
physical stores a single physical store
can be profitable and excuse me that's
what they indicate you have a turn port
they call for wall profitability and if
you build 500 such stores you know
roughly speaking 500 such stores will be
about as 500 times as profitable as one
store not quite because there are some
efficiencies but basically you know if
you're going to double your sales you
have to double your number of selling
square feet to double your number of
sales associates
so as you double sales you also double
costs that's not how our business works
we have very high fixed costs and
software development content development
in fact in some ways our business is a
lot more like yours where you know the
cost of putting business week together
is going to be largely independent of
your circulation
that's true we don't have 2.7 billion
dollars in revenue but you probably
don't have our losses whoever we're
profitable but wait I'll tell you we had
a we want to trade places is that where
we're safer we're ok where we are but
but always that's right I think we're
both well suited for our roles the I so
the next round of funding after my
parents was a group of about 20 angel
investors and they invested a million
dollars it took about four months to
raise that million dollars and it was
roughly $50,000 each from about 20
different people and recently one of
those 20 original investors gave me a
present and he wrapped it in the
original amazon.com business plan that I
had given him which I hadn't seen in
years and I looked at our year 2000
projections and we were due to have
about 70 million dollars in sales
instead of 2.7 billion but we were also
due to have a profit of about 4 million
dollars so certainly you know we adapted
our business plan
do you still have that original business
plan I do auction it off on eBay or
something now I think I'll keep that
it's it'll be worth more late it's a
nice memento yes now we're in a slump
some people say we're in a recession
does this affect your business your
sales well-being any signs of this
slowdown well I certainly wouldn't want
to give any mid-quarter guidance of any
kind other you know two days ago at our
we did reiterate guidance for the year
2001 we had already been appropriately
conservative you know back when we
announced our q4 results so this is a I
think what we're seeing here people are
probably a little jumping the gun to
call this a recession it's clearly a
slowing of growth and I think what will
come in the future is very difficult for
people to know it's very easy of course
to find people to prognosticate upon it
as if they know but I don't think very
many people really know yeah it's what's
bothered people of course is the
abruptness and the degree exactly right
I mean went from 5% growth to one at
best now very quickly in the course of a
year you know the figures I saw what
from 8% growth to 2% growth in a single
year there was one quarter of a percent
growth that's right and that's that rate
of slowdown is astonishing yeah whereas
if you look at some of the absolute
numbers they're not very upsetting but
it's the change talk a little about the
stock price you know I look at these
things and you go from 113 to a low of
about 8 little hago you're up to about
13 now how investors even begin to think
of valuing a company like Amazon well
it's very difficult um and you know we
if you look at the only way I know how
to think about amazon.com is in the very
long term because the sector that we're
in is a highly volatile sector and it
certainly was subject as everybody can
see now in 1999
to this period of irrational exuberance
to use Alan Greenspan's phrase and that
you know and if you look I mean it's
very interesting if you look at a stock
chart you know we had our IPO in May of
97 and split adjusted our IPO price was
a dollar fifty that was where the days
when we were branded Amazon toast
because you know the big bricks and
mortar retailers were coming online and
and they actually had good arguments the
people who who branded as Amazon a toast
that you know the powerful brand names
lots of purchasing power you know you
know 50 times the sales thirty thousand
employees instead of a couple hundred
employees the stock actually traded down
below its IPO price for a while so you
know you could have bought just three
and a half years ago at the time of our
IPO and was on stock for you know say
roughly a dollar twenty-five and it's up
of course you know a factor a factor of
seven or eight even today which over
three and a half years is not a bad
return you know most of the people who
bought and held from our IPO maybe they
cursed themselves for not selling it a
hundred but they certainly this is still
in many cases their single best
investment ever even today the problem
is it went via a hundred you know if it
had just been a single smooth line up
into the right everybody would be
thrilled but unfortunately that's not
how stock markets work especially in a
period of exuberance like that and a
Benjamin Graham is famous for saying
that in the short term the stock market
is a voting machine in the long term
it's a weighing machine and that's
clearly very true I've I've you know
long warned individual investors I
started doing this two years or so ago
away from amazon.com and other internet
stocks not because of the absolute price
levels because I think it's very hard at
any given point in time to be smarter
than the market but just because of the
volatility you know that if you look at
the volatility of these stocks they're
not individual investors stocks and
opinion um you know they're just a very
strong stomach they're not sleep at
night stocks that's right yeah yeah if
you are at a pro for more profit by the
fourth quarter
money is still going out because
obviously you have to finance the debt
will you need even if your pro forma
profitable and that continues well you
need additional financing well we don't
think so we've been very clear about
that and you know we've said that we
don't need any additional financing if
we were to do a financing it would be
for a strategic flexibility or to
strengthen the balance sheet but for
operating reasons we don't need it you
know we in year 2000 we raised about
seven hundred million dollars and we had
already had some 100 million at that
point so we basically you know began the
year 2000 with about 1.4 billion dollars
in cash we ended the year 2000 with
about 1.1 billion in cash so we used
about 300 million dollars in that in
that year in the year 2001 we have we we
have told people that we expect to use
about 200 million dollars in cash and
end the year with about 900 million
dollars in cash so we're very
comfortable with our cash position and
and it despite some of the things that
you read in fact we had great good news
today because Moody's the credit rating
agency it was a surprise to me came out
and said that you know they were moving
us from a stable to a positive and that
that imprint and said that by their
analysis we have at least 18 to 24
months of cash so yeah thank you all of
this obviously is it which is what we've
been saying it for a while but people
listen to Moody's more they listen to it
what have you learned from the general
dot-com crash not just the Amazon well
so I think the most important thing is
to very clearly separate it's so hard
for people to do but to very clearly
separate
the customer utility from the stock
market in other words the the companies
that are getting built really are
creating significant intrinsic value and
you know I was recently pressed on this
point by by one journalist in fact I
think it might have been a journalist
who works for you Rob off and and and I
was you know I was making this point
that that the company is not the stock
and in the clearest way I can describe
it is that you know in the year 1999
when the stock market was booming an
Amazon stock price in particular was
booming we had about 14 million
customers buy from us in that year in
the year 2000 where the stock was
busting we had about 20 million
customers buy from us so if the stock is
the company somebody forgot to tell the
customers and this is a I think this is
a very common a kind of conflation of
two very separate things and so many
there will be many winners create online
now the right analogy is that is the
Cambrian explosion 550 million years ago
this was when single-celled life
exploded at a multi-celled life and you
saw the greatest rate of speciation ever
seen but it was also the greatest rate
of extinction ever seen and that's
exactly what's going to go on here you
know it makes sense from society's point
of view for all these experiments to be
done if you're one of the extinct
species it doesn't feel too good but it
goes away in 500 million years anyway so
exactly that's the long-term
I finally got him to laugh but really
there are two sets of customers right
there the customers who buy things from
your platform and that's a great
experience the other set of customers of
course are the investors in your company
and so while it's true that is the stock
pricing is the company you have to
satisfy two sets of custom I'll tell you
the best way first of all you have to
make a decision on whether you're going
to try to satisfy all investors which I
would claim is impossible or whether
you're going to try to satisfy long-term
investors you know as I already said you
know for the people who have been with
us for you know since we first floated
our stock on the public market this is
for many of them still the single best
investment they've ever made so for our
long-term investors you know we're very
proud of our performance the and it's
very difficult to please short-term
investors I think it's a mistake because
to do to please short-term investors you
have to make trade offs which are not in
the interest of your customers whereas -
where's what long-term investors want to
do they want you to figure out how to
please your customers the way you please
long-term investors is with long-term
results and the way you get long-term
results is by offering something of
genuine value that improves people's
lives saves them time saves the money
that's the way you do that when you look
no trade-off there between customers and
shareholders and by the way you can have
this is a Warren Buffett ISM but you
know he says you can hold a rock concert
or you can hold a ballet but don't hold
a rock concert and advertise it as a
ballet you're going to make people
unhappy so you know the goal here is to
be as clear as we possibly can about the
fact that this is a company which is
inappropriate for short-term investors
and hopefully very appropriate for
long-term investors so I guess you know
we're saying we're a ballet the that
message of course got lost no fault of
yours but it got lost in the
Benzie of the last couple of years I
think that's largely right now who do
you like out there I mean there are a
lot of companies have sprung up as a
result of the internet some which offer
very unique value and things that
couldn't be done without the internet
for example eBay who do you think has
got well I think one of the very
interesting companies is Google I think
they're doing a search engine
yeah the search engine I think they're
doing a fine job so that's I think
that's uh what's their business model
how they make well that's a good
question
I not it so I not you'd have to ask them
I don't know they're there I think they
have an advertising based model which I
know is really in vogue right now and so
but they're very smart guys I've met
them and you know I I predict you know
the beginning of the right beginning is
to have something that customers value
and they certainly built that that alone
is not enough you also do need a
business model you know ours was always
simple because it was the traditional
retail business model you know you buy
products at one price and sell them at
another price so who else do you like
eBay I think eBay is a great company I
think Yahoo is a great company I know
they're under a lot of you know stress
and distress at this point in time and
going through a lot of changes just had
announced went today which I'm sure is
very troubling for them from a personal
point of view and I know the folks there
and have a great deal respect for them
they you know I but they also have built
something that's very valuable to
customers and you know they have to
figure out how to make this transition
from having lots of dot-com companies
who are willing to pay very high CPMs
for advertising you know thousand how
many dollars you pay for thousand
impressions of advertising and you know
but I think they will I think they'll
figure that out and make that transition
I think you'll I think it'll you know
there'll be some bumps but I think
they'll do it yeah for those of you who
didn't I really love this company called
amazon.com
by early by often Steve that I'm sorry I
didn't you didn't it does products not
the stock if I've got get that salad
spinner if I had gotten into dollar
twenty five you would never hear me say
but it was a hundred and thirteen you
know I'm very happy with my Eightfold
increase I was going to say for those of
you who didn't hear the news today about
Yahoo they announced that they lost
money in the first quarter and that they
laid off camera and what the number was
1200 1300 people and that's what Jeff is
referring to can Google was our guest
here just about a year ago uh so he's
having a tough time so he'll you know
he'll take all the heat now and you'll
you'll rise I am ready for anybody else
to take over the pinata job that's just
fine with me I'm as much as I like Tim
kugel he can have it well you've had a
pretty good run yeah hey let me ask you
about your investments now Amazon has
made numerous investments in a lot of
other companies you know I made a list
pets.com Webvan Ashford next car
inaudible well thanks a lot for making
that list
did you mention living no but I'll put
it on might as well add living calm okay
I did mention oh good
so what does this do for the customer
the customer in your sense not in the
investor sign well so so we made a
number of these investments you know the
two most famous ones are probably living
in pets calm neither of which is around
anymore and we invested a significant
amount of money and lost a significant
amount of money the at the time we made
those investments we were very I am
particularly a lot of people in the
company were I think for the most part
rightly convinced of the head for a long
time in a very useful metaphor for
making decisions about the internet
which was the land rush metaphor and we
knew that some of these categories pet
supplies in the case of pets calm
furniture and in the case of living calm
that they were not going to be on our
priority list any time soon so rat you
know rather than you know try to do
these categories ourself when we thought
we had you know better prospects to do
ourself we thought will kind of cover
that ship by investing in these
companies since this is a land rush mode
we don't want to miss out on this and
perhaps later we can integrate it into
the company or do something else so that
was the rash now well it just didn't
work out that way
you know what happened with these
companies is they built cost structures
which needed much higher revenue basis
to make sense and when the revenues
didn't show up fast enough for those
cost structures to bake sense because
remember as you refer back to our
earlier conversation the e-commerce is a
scale business it's very difficult to be
a small ecommerce company actually you
can be very small it's very difficult to
be a medium-sized e-commerce companies
are very tough you know sort of regime
in the middle there and they and so
within long enough financing runway
perhaps these companies could have
achieved you know acquired enough
customers to achieve the scale that they
needed to build sustaining lasting
companies but when the financing runway
or rug was pulled out from under them
that you know they had to close their
doors there was no other alternative I
mean the only alternative for us would
have been to you know put more money
into these companies to try and give him
a float that would have been an even
bigger mistake so they ran up their
costs too high too fast before they ran
up their revenue correct which you know
in a land rush model of thinking about
the world is probably the right strategy
the land rush metaphor in my opinion was
a very useful one for many years and but
some you know sometime the last couple
of years sort of faded away out of
usefulness mm-hmm do you think pets.com
the idea of having an online pet store
is a good one I do for lots of different
probably know how big that category will
ultimately be for lots of different
products it's a very good idea
probably not at least operationally the
way they were doing it for pet food
which doesn't make a lot of sense to
ship around by UPS but for different for
other kinds of you know one of the
things that's very important in online
commerce is the average selling price of
the item and you prefer high ASP items
an especially high ASP low cube item so
things that aren't that big and and and
dog food doesn't isn't great it's you
know sort of image well it's sort of
intentionally cheap per pound right I
mean you know we're not normally serving
expensive per pound foods to our dogs so
that piece of their business certainly
didn't make sense then there are all
these pet supply products which actually
probably do make sense I mean everything
from leashes and callers to stuff that's
really obscure and you have to remember
the more obscure the item in some sense
the better because the higher the
margins can be on that hard-to-find item
so you know they sold a lot of ferret
hammocks I didn't even know that ferrets
sleep in hammocks
and you know so that's probably a good
business but the problem is it's not a
very big business and so that's that's
that that's why probably that makes more
sense as a category in a multi category
store like amazon.com than it does as a
standalone business so the other thing
that we learned and we sort of knew this
but we just didn't know the degree to
which this would be true is that it was
going to be very difficult to be what we
call a mono line you know a single
category and the reason is the same that
the the fixed costs are so high you know
the e-commerce systems that we develop
are very appropriate for you know for
not just books but also for you know DVD
players you know we can use the same
system sure so it's you know it's it's
not at all impossible to to build these
systems and to you know do so at a
reasonable cost but in a land rush mode
people weren't even doing that at a
reasonable cost they were doing it in an
unreasonable cost what about the grocery
delivery business now that's a tough
business so we invested in a company
called home Gro sure which was
subsequently acquired by Webvan and I
don't know we and we now own I don't
know the exact figure but it's roughly
8% of Webvan something like that and you
know that's a very tough very
capital-intensive business so customers
like the service yeah just hard to make
a buck it's really really hard to make a
buck you need you need a very high
density of delivery density it's like
you need everybody in a neighborhood so
it should were even happen
I mean neighbor Manhattan in some ways
would be a good neighborhood Manhattan
has other problem problems as a Nessa
I lived here for eight years so I know
about some of those my first year in New
York City was very tough you know
everybody's first you New York City none
of the things if you grew up in the
suburbs as I did nothing works right in
New York you know the first thing I did
when I got
here right out of college was go buy a
television set and then I found myself
standing on a street corner holding a
television set and no cab would stop for
me and I realized that in New York you
get everything delivered but you know it
takes like a year to learn the tricks of
New York so New York is a unique place
and a lot of things work differently
here and I don't know how well web band
would work here yeah I want to ask you
two more quick question or man would be
big refrigerators that's right store the
milk or doorman with a key to your
apartment to bring it all in when your
and escort the web bad guy into your
apartment
I want to ask you about privacy do you
sell any of the information that people
give you no would you if if you sold
some assets or we sold a business you
know that it that if that customer
information was part of business of
course so that was what of course it
would go with the business and then the
new buyer could then use that
information in a way that they'd have to
use it subject to our privacy policy
because that's the private that's the
policy under which the information was
collected but of course the information
would go with it this is this is what
the policy would go with it to of course
you can't collect information either one
policy and then somehow avoid that
policy by transferring the information
okay but the issue now comes up when
companies go into chapter 11 and the
courts the bankruptcy courts say the
customer information is an asset of the
company and under bankruptcy the company
can then sell that information in a way
that the provider of the information the
original customer didn't intend well
that's why you should shop while
examining 11 that's why you should shop
in a company like Amazon accom that's
not going to go into chapter 11 okay
maybe they'll have better questions
though all right
is it as much fun as it used to be you
know the truth is I don't think this is
credible but the truth is yes um you
know sure you know I liked being the
poster child instead of the pinata a
little bit more that was good but I'm a
change junkie and I love you know the
rate of change and I love the
intellectual challenge of what we're
doing and and I love the people I work
with we've got a great team and it's fun
it's not like you know it's it's not
like you know me against the world we've
got a big team of people and we actually
you know it's there was really only one
year one year in our six-year history
where we were not the underdog and
really we're much more comfortable in
that underdog role you know we kind of
liked it when we were Amazon tossed and
it's sort of nice to be back there
well people will interpret that is that
you can delay profitability in order to
have a lot more fun does Amazon Day will
be wrong because Amazon have a b2b
strategy Amazon has always had a lot of
businesses as customers but we don't
have a specific b2b strategy you know
what we have is what we try to do is
look at segments of our customers
whatever they might be so some of our
customers are businesses some of them
are librarians a lot of them most of
them of course are individuals some of
those individuals are casual buyers who
buy infrequently some of those
individuals are very heavy buyers so we
we like we just think of these different
segments as different you know and you
know some of the segments are more
important than others in terms of how
much business they do and so on so we
focus on them as segments and for us you
know b2b is just a segment beat b2b
customers for us tend to buy you know a
hundred copies of who moved my cheese at
the same time or something like that or
you know even a thousand and we handle
those orders in a different way and so
on and there are things for each of
these segments that we can do more on
later by the way one thing to do the b2b
reminds me have if anybody is an
entrepreneur out there it was a very
clear lesson don't chase the buzzwords
it's so humorous to watch companies try
to catch a wave and you know really what
you want to do is figure out what it is
you do and you know if you're a company
that primarily serves consumers and
that's where your competencies lie and
that's what you've been focused on don't
change your business plan because that
temporarily went out of vogue you know
there were all these things early was
like a C to C then a B to B then a P to
P and then you know I it was yes but
ridiculous given the markets concern
about your liquidity situation although
you referenced Moody's next question
well I'll give it a go ahead fair chance
why don't you issue additional equity or
convertible bonds in order to move those
concerns to the market well we don't
need to raise money and you know one of
the things that we have said is that you
know as well we say we don't need to
raise money and we don't we are
reserving the flexibility to do so for
strategic reasons or to strengthen the
balance sheet which is basically what
this individual is suggesting so we're
not ruling that out but you know we're
also quite happy with our cash position
and and maybe if the you know if the
Moody's change helps things and so maybe
the climate will change a little bit and
then and maybe that won't be necessary
more yeah based on what you think
amazon.com has to do to turn an
operating profit this gets to the
questions of operating efficiency that
you were talking about do you think you
are the best CEO to do that job at
operating efficiency job I think I am
background with a lot of help so you
know we have a very deep management team
you know the people who report to me and
then and the people who report to them
if I had to do this alone I would not be
the right person you know I have now
about two years of experience in a
multi-billion dollar company we have
people on our management team of course
who have you know 10 plus years of
experience as senior executives and
multi-billion dollar companies and I
rely heavily on those folks to you know
to help guide us and help try to step
past some of the potholes
you know inevitably unfortunately you
must step in many of them but but you
can avoid many of them as well by having
a good team and I think we really do
have a good team has the success the way
I should just answer them sure reason by
the way I think I am a good person to be
the CEOs because I know so much about
the company and its history and so much
about our focus on customers that part
of it is also really really important
and so I think we can get the best of
both worlds and when it comes to you
know operating a company of our scale
I'm paying attention and
trying to learn and very happy with the
help and support that I'm getting from
our folks but sure understand this has
the success of eBay's half.com
negatively impacted Amazon's book music
and movie business no not so far as we
can tell and you know we're one of the
things we've been very successful at is
selling used I don't know if you guys
have noticed but on many of our detail
pages at this point when you go to look
at a book or music or a video you'll see
that they're also used copies available
usually for significantly less and
that's a model that's just you know it
has grown very dramatically for us and
something we're very pleased with well
this one we answered before how did you
pick the name Amazon Earth's biggest
River Earth's biggest selection it had
nothing to do with single breasted
female warriors
I never would have thought of that I
would just thought of the river this is
related to visit the privacy question
really Amazon came under fire for
altering its privacy guarantee to allow
its huge database of customer
information to be made available to
third-party marketers no is that true no
it's not true
somebody disagrees will get them
afterwards and if the rumors about a
possible strategic alliance are untrue
should they be true journalists question
right
that's like a trick question the well
today of course we did announce a major
strategic partnership with borders this
is our second one after toys-r-us I
think this is a really significant
opportunity over time for the company
and we have built this platform that
really is a unique asset and we're able
to service customers online better than
anybody else just because we've been
doing it longer and we've been really
focused on it and we're finding it there
are a number of you know leading branded
retailers who want to focus on their
in-store experience which is critical to
them and those companies I think there
are a number of them who over time may
decide to partner with us and and let us
handle the online piece their business
well the second part of this question is
about the rumors about Walmart calm
rescuing Walmart calm from itself
letting them do the fulfillment while
you handle the web traffic
infrastructure this was the rumors of
Walmart right yeah and of course any
specific prospective partnership I
wouldn't say either way that's too bad
as amazon.com have the optimal capital
structure the optimal capital structure
I've seen very few optimal things in my
life so the answer that's probably no
but but we're very happy with it I mean
if you look at the debt which I think is
if I were to answer the question that I
think is really meant to be asked you
know we have a significant amount of
debt in the form of convertible
securities but that debt the principle
in that debt doesn't come due until of
the big chunks of this convertible debt
until 2009 and the interest payments are
relatively low so you know the the we
did a billion in a quarter of converts
in the US and that has a coupon of about
four and three-quarters percent that's
very inexpensive money then we did about
700 million of Euro converts and that
has a coupon I may get this slightly
wrong I think six and seven-eighths also
very inexpensive money and so our net
interest expense per year so we also
make interest because we have a lot of
cash if you net the interest expense
it's you know eighty to ninety million
dollars a year which to have borrowed
two billion dollars or almost two
billion dollars is is actually very very
reasonable I mean that's a good
financing people sometimes say you know
do you wish that you've done that
financing with equity versus you know
convertible debt and I you know my
answer to that is the the high order bit
the important thing is that we did the
financing and then anything after that
is you know sort of a question about
optimization
I read that Merrill and Goldman have no
more stock to lend to short sellers
hence squeezes in the works are you
secretly very good well you know I I
believe that the we are a very Pole
right from the stock market point of
view
from a customer point of view we're not
a very polarizing company pretty much
everybody even our harshest critics will
agree that we do a good job for
customers so we're sort of unfortunately
dull in that way which I consider to be
really important and then when it comes
to the stock
it's an incredibly polarizing story you
know we have people who are fantastic
fans who've been with us all along and
then we have people who you know just
think that this is you know the worst
possible investment that anybody could
make and that's why you end up with
these big short positions I do think
that you know the relatively small float
makes our stock a very you know you
should definitely be a very experienced
trader to short our stock even just for
tactical reasons so the run-up in the
last few days could easily have been you
know accelerated by shorts having to
cover yeah but what do you think of the
financial media's coverage of Amazon and
the Internet well I would like to
advance in that question well yeah
there's been only one great magazine
covering us
all right next question I know when to
put my head that's right I'm a hundred
dollars doc right now
well it is so like all things it's it's
been mixed I mean I would say by and
large the coverage has been very good
and I'd say by and large and certainly
on balance you know we as a company
would have we'd be the world's biggest
whiners if we ever complained about our
media coverage on balance because on
balance the media has been very very
fair to us write that down
why are certain CDs etc available only
on Amazon as opposed to a bookstore not
sure what that question means I don't
know but I'm glad to hear that our
selection is better we do have a lot of
CDs that nobody has in part because we
have and books in and even DVDs and VHS
tapes because we have this thing called
the advantage program where we let you
know any publisher no matter how tiny
send us five copies of their work and so
it's sort of you know we'll take five on
trial and we put them up on the website
and if they sell we reorder more so that
program has been incredibly successful
and actually generated you know some
authors that have later gone on to get
major publishing contracts
how does Amazon determine the rank of
books a book may be ranked 109,000 and
then write 79,000 next week can be one
hundred eighty nine thousand the next
month yeah what does that happen though
so the ranking system is it depends on
where it is you know in the in the
ranking so if it's if it's one of the
top ten thousand best-selling books
let's say it works the same for the
other categories too cuz if it's in the
top ten thousand best-selling books then
the ranking is updated once an hour
based on a rolling window of twenty four
hours of sales if it's between the ten
thousandth bestseller and
hundred thousands bestseller it's also
updated frequently I camera if it's once
an hour or once a day and it's based on
a one-week a rolling one week's worth of
sales and then if it's beyond a hundred
thousand it's based on cumulative
lifetime to date sales so you get
volatility from just the way that's
right well if you're down at like a
million yeah that's literally like book
every two years just yeah so just a few
copies sold could actually take yep a
hundred thousand places so we could we
can manipulate your list just have to go
out at the low end of the list you're
pretty easy to manipulate it won't do
you much good I encourage it what don't
return it we can't undo the ranking and
does what percent of sales is books well
so if you look at books music and video
as a group we don't break out books
without music and video but if you look
at us BMV I'm doing this from memory but
I think in a year where we did 2.7
billion I think us B&B was about 1.7
billion cuz on right - you think it's
about right
I presumably that percentage will go
down as you has been going down and you
know diversity other big segments are
international and early stage businesses
have you got any jobs in New York City
what's that have you got any jobs in
yours is trying to laid off kamar now
you got to move to Seattle okay
will I see an Amazon catalog in my
mailbox a paper catalog you know we have
no plans to do anything like that but I
also never say never on anything like
that if it made sense for customers
something they wanted we do it
you made a big deal about doing things
for customers having a customer centric
focus and do you honestly believe the
customer is always right so it's very
interesting so our our our our mission
is what we call Earth's most customer
centric company and we have a very
precise definition for what it means to
be customer centric and it is three
things
listen invent and personalize and
listening is probably the most
traditional meaning of customer centric
and I think it's widely recognized if
you don't listen to your customers you
will fail but I think that the second
piece is most important and it often
involves not listening to your customers
and that is the invention because you
have to remember that it's not the
customer's job to invent for themselves
you know every one of our customers has
their own job and they're inventing for
their customers and if you do focus
groups and things you will often times
be led astray when it comes to invention
because customers don't necessarily know
in specific ways what it is that they
would want in fact if you describe it to
them it may say as by the way you know I
describe to many people yeah we're going
to have a million title book catalog and
you'll be able to order with your
computer and the books will come by UPS
and anybody especially who was in the
book business thought this was a
terrible idea
so it listening only gets you so far you
know there are lots of examples of this
the Sony Walkman you know they did you
know a little bit of market research and
ever he thought it was stupid so the
this is inventing it on behalf of
customers super for personalization is
putting the customer at the center of
their own universe and in designing the
store redecorating the store for each
individual customer earth's most also
has a precise definition what we mean
there is that is that our mission is
bigger than us what we want to do with
respect to customer centricity is set a
new
standard worldwide for customer
centricity and I actually use Sony as
the example very impressed by their
early mission their mission was to make
Japan known for quality this is if you
know coming out of World War two if you
look at this it wasn't to make Sony
known for quality it was to make Japan
known for caught it actually did it and
if you have a mission that's bigger than
your company then you know it's more fun
and what we want to do is uplift the
entire you know way that the world
thinks about customer centricity and if
we will be successful if every company
cop note we set this new standard which
we have to do and then if every company
copies us and says we want to be that
good at putting customers at the center
of our universe you treat all customers
the same I mean a lot of companies say
we're going to lavish a lot of marketing
attention a lot of service on the
customers that give all 80% of the
business or like Businessweek you charge
your best customers more it works right
now nobody can I change the chair do you
but you do you do you deal with your
best you know this isn't true right all
I have to do is let your subscription
run out and then they'll send you like
you know 80% off if Yuri subscribe if
you just slavish leary subscribe you pay
full price don't be fooled
it still only costs you know 49 but a
lot of companies focus a lot of tension
on their best customers and less
attention on their less good customers
do you yet well we certainly we would
like to actually do more of that at this
point in time pretty much we treat all
of our customers the same and and and we
try to treat them all really well but
you're absolutely right if you look at
some of the segments some of our
segments our customers are in a
relatively small percentage your
customers very large percentage of sales
and we would like to figure out overtime
ways to treat those customers better
they're because they're better customers
borders failed at least in the online
area why are you different I think you
touched on say borders failed well I
wouldn't say that's true I'd say they
have different goals and by the way
borders is very focused on they're in
store environment where they really are
a fantastic operator they don't wake up
every morning the lifeblood of their
company is not ecommerce yeah so but
they gave up on the online part of it so
and that's well actually I would I think
if you haven't just done about you know
15 interviews with the CEO of borders
this morning I know pretty much what he
would say and and he would say that they
have not in fact they are you know
redoubling their effort and they're
going to improve the customer experience
by outsourcing that to amazon.com and
sometimes when something isn't your core
business and e-commerce isn't their core
business it does make more sense to
outsource it to somebody who really is
focused on it like a laser do you still
have a desk made out of a door yes I do
I built the first three desks and
auctioned one of them off and on Amazon
auctions Imam was the winning bidder
and she actually was a heated
competition among several of the early
investors in amazon.com have you thought
about or by the way door desks these are
solid core door desk extremely sturdy
and they were great in the earthquake
everybody's straight under those desks
like a bomb shelter oh yeah
have you ever thought about offering
financial services for example an Amazon
bank well if we were to do something
like that you know it in overtime it
would certainly be in partnership no
that would be the exact kind of area
where sure we want to hook up with
somebody who really knows that very
specialized business and find some the
reason you would do that is because you
would have enough customers that you
would be a sort of buying cooperative
for that big group of customers and you
would somehow cut a special deal for
those customers with that Bank and then
offer it on amazon.com so that would be
the sort of customer experience
rationale for doing a project like that
and and we would have to you know it's
it's it's something that I think perhaps
makes sense but over time okay I'm just
going to ask two more questions I rarely
see advertising on your website have you
ever run ads and would you we only run
ads and they're they're not exactly ads
but only for our partners so for example
you'll see drugstore com featured you
know on our website quite prominently
and then of course we use most of the
real reason we don't run ads is because
we basically advertise our own products
so instead of you know putting up an ad
to take you to some other website to you
know see an ad for coca-cola or
something you know we're advertising
that digital camera that you can buy
with one click okay this is a fitting
question to MMS is it true you've never
ridden the elevator at your headquarters
almost true so I've never ridden the
elevator at our headquarters since we
moved into the building and but I did
when we were looking at the building
before we leased it I rode the elevators
I rue that day why no I'm just kidding I
don't you dumb why don't you run well
it's an exercise plan and what I found
is a very good motivational technique
for me and exercise which the two of us
don't get along that well and a good
motivational tech for me is the winning
streak so if I can say to myself I've
never ridden that elevator since we
actually moved into the building then
it's like now that that it's been two
years where you know and this is a this
is a 12 story building so and I have
meetings on all the floors there's a lot
of stairs I lived in a fourth floor
walk-up on the east side at one point
that was nothing and so it's actually a
reasonably good amount of exercise sort
of integrated into my day and now you
know even if I have the of the flu or
something I come in I look longingly at
that elevator and then I think about the
fact that I'd be breaking my winning
streak and I drag myself up the stairs
well great so you have your Stairmaster
at work and you use it all the time
absolutely Jeff thank you very very much
thank you
American perspectives will continue in a
moment
a